avec nous ce soir pierre karl péladeau
le président et chef de la direction de
quebecor bonsoir monsieur péladeau bon
sens monsieur fignon
avant de parler de vidéotron parlons de
transat
quelles sont vos intentions où en êtes
vous par rapport à transat
écoutez il est vrai que donc j'étais
intéressée à faire l'acquisition de
l'ensemble des actions de transat nous
donnions j'ai fait une proposition au
conseil d'administration il ya déjà de
ce plusieurs mois j'en ai fait une
seconde est arrivée ensuite il ya une
cascade d'événements comme vous le savez
oui il ya eu un retrait d'air canada
entre-temps également aussi n'ont qu'a
eu des déclarations du plus importante
actionnaires en l'occurrence les deux co
brosseau il dit que donc à 5 dollars et
ils n'accepteront pas une offre allant
les choses ont évolué
malheureusement pas nécessairement dans
la meilleure des directions oui il ya eu
l'annoncé du financement l'ifla donc du
gouvernement fédéral mais il est
important de souligner qu'il s'agit d'un
jeune enfant en dn1 donc ce sont des
centaines de millions de dollars de
dettes qui vont s'accumuler dans dans le
bilan de transat et dont il abuse être
qu a décidé lui de considérer que
l'offre à 5 $ et tes portes étaient pas
intéressant je les invite à en faire
l'acquisition de l'entreprise et la
diriger lui-même alors à ce moment là et
donc est ce que vous avez une offre est
ce que vous déposez une offre est ce que
vous retirez est ce que vous vous
retirer du dossier complètement
moi je pense que ça donne absolument
rien de faire une offre dont on aussi
que le principal actionnaire ont refusé
parce qu'il s'est déclarée publiquement
à des accords avaient alors vous faut
comprendre que si on a d'autres choses à
faire que de de s'engager dans une
impasse
donc vous sortez du dossier monsieur
péladeau exact c'est terminé il y aura
pas de propositions de votre part pour
transat en tout cas certainement pas
pour l'instant étant donné que les
circonstances nous amène à conclure que
le principal intérêt si donc le
principal actionnaire heureux à des
expectatives ton déraisonnable monsieur
eustache avait des bons mots pour vous
lors de sa conférence et quelques jours
ils vous disaient qu'ils vous étiez très
intelligent il semblait y avoir une une
forme de deux de bonnes négociations ou
de bonne de bons contacts avec vous oui
oui j'ai beaucoup de steam pour rage
avant que ce stage j'ai eu même le
privilège de mieux le connaître et les
délais de j'étais administrateur de
quebecor il ya de ça quelques années un
je pense qu'ils le montent effectivement
une activité une entreprise pour
lesquels les québécoises et les
québécois sont très fiers
mais bon c'est pas lui qui décide ultime
en deux sont les actionnaires et le plus
important des actionnaires considèrent
que lorsque j'ai faire 5 dollars était
pas à la hauteur de ses expectative donc
ok je vous amène sur vidéotron sur tb
corp résultats financiers au cours des
derniers jours puis aujourd'hui
assemblée de quebecor vous êtes le pdg
de quebecor
vous êtes maintenant le président
bientôt de vidéotron parce que monsieur
bruno va quitter ses fonctions le 4
janvier vous êtes le pdg du groupe tva
par intérim
vous avez les mains sur toutes les
manettes en ce moment de votre
entreprise monsieur péladeau est ce qu'à
un certain moment vous ne craignez pas
que les actionnaires les analystes ne
trouvent que c'est trop
c'est le 4 juin vous avez 10 janvier non
mais c'est le cas d'un oui bon écoutez
donc oui les analystes vous savez on
nous avons des discussions et des
conversations continue avec eux
on vient d'avoir notre notre appel
conférence avec les analystes à bell qui
se déroule à tous les trimestres
ils sont évidemment on les connaît tous
parce que donc c'est toujours les mêmes
analystes suivent les entreprises et
certains récemment les élèves certain
monsieur péladeau disait récemment c'est
problématique c'est négatif que monsieur
bruno senna est lui qui est qui qui
dirigeait les affaires la direction
financière pendant des années de
quebecor et qui dirige et vidéotron
seulement depuis le début de 2010 9
oui mais jean françois a décidé de
prendre sa retraite se retirer de faire
autre chose qu'à vénale cours normal des
activités une entreprise j ai déjà car
il ya des gens qui partent
je pense que ce qui est important de
mentionner c'est que et c'est une équipe
et que ce soit le conseil
d'adminstration où que ce soit le pdg de
quebecor la responsabilité qui leur
échoit est de faire en sorte qu'il soit
entouré donc d'une équipe solide et
c'est ce à quoi donc nous avons
construit l'entreprise et ce à quoi nous
allons poursuivre je comprends dans les
années qui viennent
mais le monsieur bruno est parti et
madame nozière et et fait quelques
autres choses je ne sais pas quoi atd à
un autre défi professionnel en attendant
donc on a l'impression vous avez dit ce
matin en conférence que vous ne voulez
pas être un one man show mais est-ce que
ça ressemble pas à ça présentement un
budget plutôt il dit contraire c'est
qu'effectivement non qu'il y ait des
équipes et faisait référence à mon père
parce que à l'époque on disait que c'en
était un
aissi taveri à être que ce n'était pas
ce qu'il y avait autour de lui donc que
des collaborateurs de grand talent à qui
on fait en sorte que la transition s'est
relativement belle sait très bien que
perry même pot relativement dit très
bien opéré donc d'une génération à
l'autre si s'cusez et c'est ce à quoi
donc encore une fois le conseil et
moi-même tard don de faire en sorte que
les équipes soient solides et elles le
sont solides
un mot sur vidéotron sur la suite des
choses
enchères de spectre le mois prochain est
ce que la priorité pour vidéotron en ce
moment c'est de prendre de l'expansion à
l'extérieur du québec ailleurs au canada
de saisir les opportunités qui peuvent
se présenter
il ya eu une décision monsieur fignon
était rendu récemment donc par le crtc
une décision qu'on appelle la décision m
viennot donc un mobile virtual network
offre exclusive mois là l'anglicisme
mais c'est la possibilité donc d'un
opérateur d'utiliser les tables et de
leur réseau d'un opérateur historique et
en a 3 comme vous savez telus bell et
rogers mais c'est vrai qu'ici quand même
au québec et en os 4 il y en a quatre
maintenant aussi quand même dans une
grande partie du canada et c'est le
résoudre de choc
donc ça permet à l'opérateur de venir
s'installer de commercialiser des
services
les conditions ne sont pas entièrement
pour l'instant déterminer
l'obligation est faite dorénavant donc
de recevoir un nouvel opérateur
donc ça constitue pour nous évidemment
un potentiel qui nous amènerait à sortir
de notre marché historique du québec
j'ai eu également aussi l'occasion et
les mêmes questions sont convenus de la
part des analystes l'ajustement au
confess de référence un peu plus tôt si
nous étions intéressés donc à faire
l'acquisition de fruits de maubert que
deux mots balle étant l'opérateur sans
fil de choc qui a fait l'objet comme
vous le savez donc d'une offre d'achat à
rogers je pense que le hors de tout
doute
il s'est avéré qu'un quatrième opérateur
a fait baisser les prix c'est une
politique publique que les gouvernements
le gouvernement canadien tente de mettre
en place le crtc et le bureau de la
concurrence en sont venus à la
conclusion que c'est au québec que les
québécois vous que les canadiens
bénéficient des meilleurs tarifs qui
n'était pas le cas ailleurs en raison du
fait justement de l'existence du
quatrième opérateur qui ont ainsi au
québec et vidéotron très bien alors
merci monsieur péladeau d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir d'avoir fait le point sur
plusieurs de ces dossiers dont celui de
transat on a compris norma le message
merci monsieur péladeau gens prient
merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d